so
good afternoon everybody um i'm phillip
i'll walk you for the next 50 or so
minutes through a couple of
elasticsearch things and just to get a
quick idea who is already using
elasticsearch
who has no idea what elasticsearch is
okay very few um
i would have a ton of slides but i don't
want to show you a million slides um we
will draw all of this out on the
whiteboard
so we'll do it more interactively if you
have any questions just shout and ask
um for good questions or answers i also
have these bouncy balls that are
supposed to blink and i'll throw these
at you um so don't fall asleep otherwise
a bouncy ball might hit you at some
point
um that's the other thing we can do with
those so um
and like i said we would have a ton of
slides but we will not do slides i've
i've done too many slides recently and
we'll we'll do this differently so for
those of you who have never heard of
elasticsearch um i've just stumbled
today across something that was
aggregating github stats and the nice
thing is in terms of various metrics
like stars pull requests
loads
pull request creators and
also issues though i'm not sure if
issues is a great metric elasticsearch
is one of the most popular data source
or the most popular data store on github
as of today and we've had the most
issues for a long time i'm not sure
there's a bug or a feature but that is a
different thing so when you use
elasticsearch and i have started the
cluster already um we have the current
version running here
which tells me it's 8.2.2 which is fine
and that one what you normally would do
is um you would then add a document so
you could just say
post post
let's say it's a test document
and i want to add a document
and then i say i don't know
my name is
and then it will do something and it
will tell me that it this was successful
and it was written successfully twice
and we'll figure out why twice and
version one and we'll get back to all of
these um
but this looks very simple right
and kind of like we'll now open the hood
and see what is happening behind the
scenes in all of this um starting with
um what is the cluster and by the way if
you've ever seen the elastic logo um
looks like this there are a couple of
stickers next to the feedback box take
the stickers afterwards so i don't have
to carry them home but the elastic logo
looks like this um this is not a flower
as some people think and this is a
cluster and you can see these little
colored pieces here these are the
so-called charts we'll get to the shards
later on but this is very related to
what elasticsearch does and where it's
coming from and this is why the logo
looks like this
so
the
basic thing is um we we wrote this
document and it came into my cluster and
then my cluster did something and it was
just working and
the simplest way to run the cluster in
elasticsearch is you could run the
binary on windows linux as a docker
image and various other ways
and what you would have is you have a
node and i'll just say this is my node
and your write operation comes in here
and then it sends out the response
afterwards it also sends back out of the
cluster now this is the very simple
cluster that you could have obviously
you want to have more than a single node
because a you might want to scale and b
you want to have some high availability
so if that node
goes down we wouldn't succeed in that so
we will need to add a second node
for those who have used elasticsearch in
the past can i have a cluster with two
nodes
in elasticsearch
yes i so yeah so there so there is a
very big caveat um and i'll
i say i'll give you a bouncy ball for
that um
so yes you can do that um but this is a
very bad idea and you should not do this
um
why because elasticsearch is based on a
quorum concept so there is something
called the cluster state and the cluster
state is basically how is the cluster
organized it's not the the data itself
but it's the metadata of your cluster
and that keeps track of which
indices and charts will get to those
concepts but which things of information
do you have what notes do you have there
what are the the mappings also called
schemas in your cluster so all of these
need to be stored in the cluster
and the problem is this is a quorum
system because maybe you've heard of the
cap theorem consistency availability
petition tolerance and you can have at
most two of those three
so the problem is if you have only two
nodes and the network between those two
nodes breaks
which note is still alive or the right
one because you could either write them
to this one or to that one and they
wouldn't know if the other one is there
and the so-called cluster state can only
be managed by one
so-called masternode is already
mentioned so there are multiple master
eligible nodes and they vote the current
master
and you need a quorum for that and a
quorum is made out of normally an odd
number because you need to have the
election so normally you will would have
a third node um
and these three then if the network
between
those here breaks then this node would
know i don't see the other two i'm
isolated i cannot be
keeping track of the current cluster
state um i can't do anything whereas
these two as long as they see each other
they know we're in the majority so
whatever happens we are keeping that
cluster alive and then those two for
example um would
make the
let's say this is a little crown and
this one would be the current uh
masternode of that cluster so the
the minimum you need to have in any
highly available cluster is three nodes
um otherwise either you are not highly
available because you have a single node
or you could have two nodes um
but then only one could be master
eligible because that would then decide
and keep track of the cluster state
because with two there is no no quorum
and you couldn't keep track of that yes
your cluster is dead
so
yes so if you don't have a majority
anymore in your cluster then the cluster
will just stop so if you if you have a
very volatile environment and you say
like maybe i lose two of those master
eligible nodes at once
how many master eligible nodes would you
need
five because you still need that
majority of three so you could then lose
two so anybody who has an even number of
master eligible nodes um is probably not
doing their themselves a favor because
if i have four master eligible nodes
what is the majority of four
three so i can still only lose one
single note so you're not doing yourself
any favor um so that's um
um
that that that's not any good so this is
the cluster and so far i have talked
only about the so-called
master eligible nodes or masternode
there can only be one masternode at once
we had box in the past if that there are
multiple masternodes that will mean a
very bad day for your cluster um
there was one concept we've had for a
long time which was called minimum
masternodes where you had to set what is
the minimum so if you had three master
eligible nodes you would need to set
that to two so that your cluster knows
what is the majority we have
removed that concept by now
we now have a bootstrapping concept
where the nodes find each other and once
they have formed a stable cluster the
cluster itself will keep track of how
many master eligible nodes you have
and what is the majority of that so you
cannot miscalculate and you also don't
have problems if you scale your master
eligible nodes up or down your cluster
will keep track of that because that was
in older versions one of the or probably
the number one reason why you screwed up
your cluster was that the minimum master
nodes were not configured correctly and
then they would basically break into two
separate clusters and there was no way
to reconcile that so by now you only
basically in the configuration when you
bootstrap a cluster you would only only
need to tell the nodes like hey there
are these other nodes and you would say
like this is master eligibility or
master eligible and they will then
figure out okay we have formed the
majority we form
or we elect or vote for a master node we
form a stable cluster and then they just
work and whatever you change in the
cluster as long as you don't remove more
than half of the master eligible nodes
at once
your cluster will just keep working and
doing everything for you but this was a
big pain point in the past that we got
rid of
um
so far our cluster hasn't done anything
useful because i was just talking about
metadata right we actually normally care
about the actual data so besides being
master eligible there are various other
roles a cluster can have so that the
default role that we would have is a
so-called data node that's one that
stores data there are other roles like
ingest which is doing an interest
processing so if you have log lines and
you need to break them apart with
regular expressions
um an interest note could do that who
likes writing regular expressions
okay that's the stockholm syndrome right
um
there are better ways than that but
that's a different discussion anyway so
you have um
you have your data nodes um there are
other node types that we could have as
well so there are client only nodes
which are like
like a smart proxy or load balance in
the cluster
which might not be that useful and
needed anymore we also have some machine
learning components so by default your
nodes have all of these roles but if you
have a very large cluster you would
break them out into different roles so
for example that ingest node that runs
irregular expressions would mostly need
cpu to do all the parsing but it
wouldn't need so much memory and disk
whereas your data nodes which store all
the data would have a different hardware
profile so once you have a larger
cluster you would have different roles
and you would break them out to use
better hardware profiles to make it more
cost efficient and performant
um but that is only for a
from a certain size on i would say like
if you have nine or more notes or so you
could start thinking about breaking out
the different rows but you will always
need
at least two for high available
availability of each roll type except
for the master eligible nodes where you
always need three for the majority
and then you could structure your
clusters also for stability we often
recommend for larger clusters like nine
plus or so to have so-called dedicated
masternodes
which only have the role of that master
because
if the nodes with that cluster state are
running some queries and run out of
memory and die your cluster again will
have a very bad day because no master
nodes um pretty much everything stops
and breaks so from a certain size on you
probably want to break those out in a
into a specific or into a dedicated node
to avoid those problems and have higher
cluster stability um
so just to give you an idea what i have
running here is um
i use the so-called cat api which gives
us in human readable form shows us what
is going on in the cluster and i'm
interested in the notes here
and actually
just shows you a lot of almost random
numbers and things
and i'll just add the so-called oops
lowercase it should lower case
v parameter and that then adds the
headers and then you can see what is
going on in here so you can see i have a
cluster with three nodes um
this is the ip this is the the heap and
ram
used the cpu i have assigned to those
the load then we have various rows i'll
get into those into a moment in a moment
all three here are master eligible
because only three nodes so we need a
majority and this one with that little
star this is the currently elected
master and then you have
well the names and you can see my
cluster is basically using two and a
half nodes because it's using two full
nodes and then a so-called tie breaker
this tiebreaker is only there really to
to decide in the vote um
to guarantee that majority but here i
like you said before i almost have a two
node cluster but not quite we have the
tie breaker too to keep the high
availability
and then these are
the the node rows and attributes that my
node has so this is a master eligible
nodes but b means voting only so this
can only vote
and then these these have a lot of other
um rows so for example
i stands for ingest h is hot data we'll
get to hot data a bit later um
master eligible um and a couple of other
roles um these are very hard to remember
and you always need to look them up in
the documentation or at least i need to
do that but these are the the node
attributes that we have set on this
cluster here so this is the the cluster
and the node type so far um we've talked
about
discovery basically you need to tell
this node and there is this other node
and if this node knows this one it would
tell it so you don't need to tell this
node all the other nodes in the cluster
but as long as a node knows at least one
other node in the cluster it would share
the
topology of your cluster
and i think that's more or less it for
the cluster and the cluster coordination
so far so good
good
the next thing that we have i wrote my
one document and then we have this these
concepts called index and chart in
elasticsearch um so um
if i write that document from before
again
it would tell me something about charts
here and the total count of two and
successful two um what happened here
behind the scenes so when you do a write
operation um
wherever i put my black pen um so
basically the write operation comes in
and i say i write to the index
and the index that i'm writing to would
say like it's called database and this
index then consists or the index is
basically a collection of similar or
related documents and this index can
then be broken up into so-called shards
so under this basically we have shards
the default by now is that one index has
exactly one chart if you were using an
older version does anybody remember how
many
primary shots we had back then
five yes
whoever was first
um
and that is the unit of scaling so one
chart always lives on one of these nodes
um so if i have only one all the data
for this index would be written let's
say
on this node
so that the chart is how do to break
that up initially we had five primary
shots because it was very cool to show
that how the data is split up over
multiple nodes and how it can
automatically scale up and down so if i
add more nodes to my cluster or if i
remove nodes the shards will
automatically be moved as needed in the
cluster
one is kind of like a dumb number to
show that right why did we change that
because most people had the problem that
they had way too many shards so there
was some kind of or there is a bit of an
overhead to each chart
um also because
distributing data if you don't need it
can be a bit costly um that's why we
switched the default to one
chart
if you have a lot of data
you will need more shots does anybody
have any idea how large a chart should
approximately be yes please
yes so it so
okay i'll hit five people now because
this is packaged and it's a bit hard to
throw but
please forward if it doesn't reach you
um
so
the the size of chart so the favorite
saying at elastic that we have is it
depends um because it might depend on
your hardware and your use case so a
full text search use case might be a bit
smaller have the optimal size um larger
like logs use cases generally have that
50 gig limit um we have also seen people
push it a bit further because we have
done some optimizations that some things
in the heap are smaller but 50 gigabytes
is definitely very good default number
if you aim for that that's also if you
have a logs use case what we would
configure by default for charts to fill
up before we start a new one
um
so we have that chart
now
i've mentioned the high availability
with the with the master eligible nodes
um what you actually have is a so-called
primary shot and the replica shot so
this primary or this shot is broken up
in
one primary
and there is exactly one
and then optional you have
zero to n replica
shots and
the primary shot is basically let's say
we we write our little document comes in
here and we write our document here
and then it gets replicated let's say we
keep the default replication factor of
one so we create one second copy so in
total we have two copies of the data
and that replica will then be
written here on that node um
so if this node goes down the data is
still here everything keeps working
if you do any read or search operation
you could go either to this node or to
that node because both have the same
data and would fulfill your search
request
if this node goes down
you can still go to this node um
would my cluster try to fix that there
is only one copy now
yes
after a one minute timeout by default
it would then start re-replicating that
data to this other node so that you have
two copies again so it would do that
automatically for you
if i have a single node cluster which is
not highly available and i configure one
primary shot which i always need to have
and one replica shot would i have one or
two copies of that data on my single
node
yes
yes why
exactly yes it doesn't make much sense i
the only thing if i
so this is not possible but if i wrote
my second copy here the replica on the
same note i wouldn't gain anything i
just doubled the disk space but it's i'm
not getting more um availability because
if the node goes down both copies go
down or disappear also i would just
double that the disk space used on this
one so i i'm not gaining anything from
that so replicas can only be on one
other node you can by the way configure
replicas not just as a fixed number but
you could even say like zero to n
because the the cluster if you have a
single node cluster and you configure or
keep the default of one replica shot
your cluster would always say like you
told me to keep a second copy of this
data but i can only keep one single copy
because there's only one node and that
would affect the the cluster state or
the health of your cluster but you could
also say that in how many copies you
want to have you could say zero to one
so your cluster would automatically know
there's a single node i'll keep a single
copy
there are two or more nodes i will keep
two two copies of the data
so you can keep that configurable um so
that is the
what's your question
no good um so uh that was
yeah
yes
should we do that right now i mean we
can i wanted to do it a little later but
um we can do the anatomy of like a an
operation right away so let me
let me start over let's say we have a
very simple use case where we have three
nodes um so we have
node one
two
three um
we say this one here is the master even
though it doesn't really matter
and let's say we have the
we have a put or a post
we have that coming into that node
um every document um has a so-called id
um you can see that here in that
underscore id field that is the id it's
by default randomly generated if you do
a post
otherwise you could do a put
copy that i don't have to type all of
this
and this is by the way all curl commands
basically um so
read this as curl x post
this is the end point and then this is
the json document so this is a rest api
elastic search exposes it on port 9200
by default and this is just in kibana we
have this slightly more compact syntax
to write it but it's absolutely the same
so here you could say put document you
provide the id manually and then you
would write the same document and it has
the id
one if you don't provide the id
um
so this is put or post
with post um
this node here would automatically
generate the id for you
so you have then
you have underscore id and you have
whatever id you have
so in the put you provided and the post
it
generates the id for you what you do
then is
you
hash the chart sorry you hash the id you
calculated modulo number the primary
charts
and that tells you where it should go so
what you do is
you have the
you do a hash function oops hash
of underscore id and then you calculate
it modulo the number of primary shards
um so for example in that case if you
only have one primary chart it's a bit
boring but if you have five let's say we
have five primary shots then it would
calculate
modulo five and and that would give you
then let's say
node 3
or shard 3. um and it would then
look into that in that cluster state
chart 3 of this index is located on
which node
so
why do i hash this why don't i just take
the id modulo five
yes exactly because otherwise i might
get a hotspot so for example if i have
the ids and i use the the name for
example
oops sorry
for
and and then you don't have that key
space evenly distributed you would get a
hotspot on one node so that's why you
use a hashing function and to evenly
distribute the data by the way
in the very early versions of
elasticsearch we used a bad hashing
function and that very unevenly
distributed the data if you used
33 primary shots
that was a bug or a limitation in the
in the hashing function but of course
somebody figured that out because then
some shards would get zero documents and
others had tons um
and so the initial uh hashing function
we had dj b2 from dj bernstein who is a
big in cryptographer
and now we are using murmur 3 which is
also a widely used hash function in the
end you want something that is evenly
distributed and pretty fast to calculate
so
we've hashed the id we calculated
modular number of primary shards and it
says chart three is where this document
goes and let's say we have my cluster
has allocated chart three on this node
here so what it then does is um
then
let's say this is then
so this here the first node you're
hitting is the so-called coordinating
node because it coordinates that right
um it can be any node um normally we
would round robin between all the nodes
so also that load is evenly distributed
in your cluster um it then says um
go to
god3 because let's say this is this node
has shard three and then you you write
that document here as the primary chart
and then it also says the replica shot
of 3 is on let's say this node so then
it would
replicate the document to here and what
then happens once you have written this
this node so this this the node that
writes does some basic checking if this
operation can actually be fulfilled
otherwise it would recheck the right
right away if it can do that it will
replicate the data
so
maybe i should number this a bit better
so you have
this is the first step this is the
second step this is the third step and
then you have
here
you get an act back
that's the fourth step
and then you get i'm getting lost in my
colors
you get
an egg back here in step 5 and then in
step
6 at the end
this is when your client whatever like
programming language curl whatever gets
the acknowledgement back from your write
operation so it basically works its way
through the entire cluster just because
it's distributed like that in this
example it could be any on any node um
but this is how a write operation works
good
cool yes please
yes i mean the
thing is
the same um just this part here is
different
yes you only have one primary shot
so it but i mean the right operation
looks the same but the thing is if you
have five um you i could have like
primary shots like let's say two primary
shots here two primary shots here one
primary shot here
so that the data of that
index could be distributed amongst the
nodes and the load as well
to write them so with the five let's say
i have blue is that the number of
primary shots so i have two primary
shots here two primary shots here and
one primary shot here and then the
replicas would be of course like always
not on the same note but then let's say
we have
three replicas here because it doesn't
matter we have
one replica here and one replica here so
they would just if you have five primary
shots and five replica shards they could
just be more evenly distributed whereas
if you have three nodes and only one
primary and one replica chart
all the data would only go to two nodes
um
because normally you have a lot of
indices to write and there's an overhead
and most people have way too little data
for multiple shots
um so that
we have seen clusters which had i don't
know thousands of charts and that
basically kept the cluster busy just
keeping track of the shots and
everything which was a very common
occurrence um a we have changed a bit
the tooling and the defaults behind it
so we have view of that b we have a
project that we call many shards so by
now you can actually have thousands of
shards per cluster previously we had
like a rough calculation per gigabyte of
heap you should only have 20 shards
approximately but that calculation is
very outdated by now so you can you can
have a lot more
but because of these things um we went
down to one
because normally you have multiple
indices or if you have logs um you you
write them for some specific time frame
and then you roll over to the next index
you you will have a lot of shards in
your system going on normally anyway
but if you have a specific use case and
you only have one index
set the number of shots correctly
um
okay so that was the anatomy of a right
so far yep yes please
so
that the number of sharks is picked up
front but there are two apis that you
can
use now they are called split
and shrink
so these are basically you
what you would need to do is you have
index let's say one primary chart foo
and the api call would be foo
slash underscore split slash um the
target index so you would need to rename
it but you can change it the number of
primary shots with that operation and
that is actually very fast because it's
just doing some zoom linking on the on
the disk um to either split it so it
keeps like some virtual splitting in the
background running um or it could
combine them so you can do it at any
point in time you need to change the
name of the index but with aliases you
could fix that afterwards again but you
can split and drink at any point since
six point something i think
so a couple of years um it was a big
limitation a long time ago but not
anymore yes please
yes
i mean the i think
i think that so the the primary shot if
i remember correctly will start the
replication on all nodes but it will
wait for the majority of replicas to
respond because then it's sure that it's
correctly written and then it will
acknowledge it so it will not
necessarily wait for all of them but the
majority because there is always this
failure scenario if like n nodes die
what are your replicas worth so you
always need to have the majority
acknowledge that all of them have the
same data otherwise you might be in
trouble and actually that is it sounds
like an uncommon scenario but i know a
big german
dropping retailer whatever and they have
something like 30 or more replicas
because search operations can go to any
copy primary or replica and they just
want to parallelize their search so much
and for them latency is very important
because otherwise people append on the
search um so they they have i think
one shot or maybe two shards or so um
but then a ton of copies just to keep
that um
quick which is by the way a good point
how do you scale your rights you have
more charts so you can parallelize the
writing how do you scale your reads you
have more replicas because then you have
more copies from where you can answer
um hope that makes sense
um
um so that was a search um
sorry that was a right yes please
yes if you don't provide it it is being
generated on the first note yes
yeah it's something i think the number
of stars and whatever it's like it's
it's pretty much impossible um
so
i don't
i forgot the actual details of how
unlikely it was um but there was a
calculation if for a hundred years you
write a million operations a second and
then you have a 50 chance or something
like that um and that is way more data
than you normally have in an index um
so uh that should not be a practical
concern yes please
but i mean so if you provide the id
yes
also because so what this operation
actually does is if you do a put the put
when you provide the id could actually
overwrite an existing document so you
always need to read first and check if
i'm replacing or writing a new
if you do a post it basically has an
operation attached that it says create
and it wouldn't overwrite anything
but any such collisions are more
theoretical i don't think that is
anything that would hit you in practice
um
everybody good um then should we do a
search because so far we have um
only
written so we have
we have three notes again
and we do a search um
what is the right http verb for research
get um
or post yes um
why is that so yes we use get or post
why is that
yes because our searches are i mean uh
yeah so a search operation could look uh
like i i would use the index and then i
would say search this is the endpoint um
oops
and then i
would need to say um i i i want to do a
query
um and then in the query i don't know i
want to do a match
and then i say i have a name
and then the name is philip
then my two documents or three documents
that i've written so far will come back
now
get cannot have a body
um i can do the same with the post
yeah it shouldn't it's not in the spec
um and using post for right up for a
read operation is also weird so there is
no winning here and we kind of don't
care and we're pragmatic so it's
it's up to you the post generally people
frown upon because it's the wrong http
verb the bigger problem is normally they
get because sometimes when people run
some reverse proxies they discard the
body silently or some some curing tools
because they don't expect the body there
and then you just run
this because it discards the body and
the tricky thing is this gives you 10
random documents from the
thing so it looks like all your searches
are broken um so generally i i tend to
use get but post is kind of safer
because you won't run into any such
issues
so
our search get our post is coming in and
i'll just say we're hitting the search
endpoint and it's coming in here and
this is again the coordinating node
and i have we said i don't know the
colors are doesn't don't matter but
let's say we have the primary shot here
and we have the
replica shot here and actually let's say
we have an index with two shards to make
it a bit more interesting and we have
that the replica zero here and the
replica one shot here and then we have
obviously the primary shot zero here and
the replica shot one is here this is a
bit of a constructed
problem of course but it doesn't really
matter so your search query comes in and
you're searching for all the users that
are called philip
um and we can search either
primary or replica so it doesn't matter
um
but actually this is a so-called
two-step approach how the search
operation works um we call it um
scattergather oops
yeah
there this is what we call it um so
because if i'm doing this search
operation um
and
voltex search is not just about exact
matches but more this like concept of
what i might search so there is always
the so-called score here how well
is this document fitting my search query
so it's like the relevancy rating that
you have in the search engine as well
um and let's assume we have millions of
documents and we have like a search
query that might hit 100 documents by
default the search only gives you 10
documents back you can change that of
course with the size parameter but it
only gives you 10 documents back it
would however be very wasteful for this
coordinating node to say
to each node like give me all the
results and then just
send all of them back because the search
operation is only by default getting us
the top 10 results so what it does is it
goes the coordinating node goes
to each chart and it doesn't matter if
primary replica but it goes to 0 and 1
and says like
please give me your top 10 results for
this search and it only gets back the
document id
and the score and then the coordinating
node
will get
how many sub results back
20 so 10 from each primary shot because
10 is the total number it wants to get
back and then it sorts them and figures
out overall these are the 10 top
documents and then it fetches by id and
it fetches the actual documents in the
second round from these so basically
what what you have is
you have the scatter phase
it goes to the notes and says like
give me back the documents and you will
get back um the i
id of the document and the score
um and then it will get
another in the second round so this is
basically phase zero and then there is
um
the phase one and this is a
get by id so it's then getting the
documents putting together the final
result and then you're getting the
documents back
obviously if you have
a hundred charts
this is also more expensive because then
you need to get 10 sub results from 100
charts combine them figure out the top
10 and then fetch those if you have a
single shard
this is a lot zipper um
so this is another reason why you don't
want to go too crazy
um
okay so that was uh
get so far so good
timing-wise we still have 20 minutes
i probably have material for three more
hours but we'll we'll figure out what
makes most sense
no questions so far yep please
yes the shard i mean decreased you would
need to do a split um
and and then it will decrease um but
otherwise it will just keep increasing
which is a good point um because under
the hood of all of this when you write
data there is apache lucene is the
library writing actually to disk because
sometimes people are asking like what is
actually writing and doing all of that
um so that's a petulus scene and the the
clever trick or the combination of
elasticsearch and lucine is um lucine is
really a library for java developers and
elasticsearch is kind of the wrapper
around it it provides the rest api the
query dsl it does the distribution
replication balancing of the cluster and
everything but for leucine it looks like
and that is unfortunately bit
unfortunate what we call an
elasticsearch index is made up of
multiple shards and each shard is the
so-called lucine index
this kind of index here index there but
lucine
thinks that it's lucine index the shard
is the whole world whereas elasticsearch
knows there are multiple ones i'll get
the results from all of them and combine
them but that's kind of like how the two
are related
um and
lucine is writing the data and that's
the the so-called chart size
actually how lucine works and this is
maybe a good addition to the the thing
from before
or i don't really have enough space here
um and i'll stay on the top so everybody
can see that so when you have a right
and it doesn't matter if it's a post or
a put coming in
into elasticsearch what happens so
there is a so-called um we have
a buffer
this is where the document gets kind of
like put at first
and then the acknowledgement and
whatever works so this is within one
node now so this is the buffer um that
happens in lucine um and then
this buffer is being taken and written
out into a so-called segment
this is the lucine concept
and segments are immutable by default
they are written once every second maybe
you have seen refresh once a second is
the default um so all the documents that
accumulate within one second are
buffered and then written out into a
segment
for durability of your data there is
another concept um coming from that
buffer um and that is the so-called
trench log the transaction log
um
which is immediately written to disk and
is just sequentially written so it's
very cheap to write um whereas this does
more and does some analysis so there is
some more overhead here these are also
at first only um written
in memory and only once that data is
f-synced to disk the trends log with all
the other write operations on is can be
removed
so basically
a write operation comes in here
it's
put or let's say it's then immediately
put into the trends log
another write operation comes in here
it's again immediately put in turns lock
the one second timeout is kind of over
we create a new segment so we create a
segment with
those these two write operations these
just exist in memory potentially you get
multiple of these
once these are flushed to disk um
then
only these are taken out
and that's how the transaction lock
works but most data stores like postgres
mysql whatever um they have something
called or i think postgres calls it the
transaction log mysql a bin log but it's
kind of like the same concept that you
have this thing that writes all the data
for durability immediately
and that is how a write works the thing
is the segments are immutable and i'm
coming back to your question now
so that
this is immutable every time you update
a document it's basically marked for
deletion in the segment and written a
new
this is a bit unfortunate because this
makes small updates very expensive in
elasticsearch so if you have a very
large document with 100 fields and you
update a single document you still need
to rewrite the entire document every
time you update that there are some ways
around to structure that and do that but
that's the the basic law because of
lucine because of the immutability which
has some other nice attributes but that
is one of the downsides um so these
small segments once every second by
default are being written
after some time you have hundreds of
thousands of those and then there is a
so-called merge happening where you
combine multiple of these rights also
all the documents that have been
replaced or deleted are then
removed and only like the current
documents are being written into the
larger segment so multiple small
segments over time are aggregated into
larger segments over time
um so that this space might sometimes be
fluctuating or a bit higher than what
you would expect based on those mergers
and the mergers just happened in the
background
that was
this
there is one other thing that i have um
that i have kind of glanced over let's
write another document um so we have
seen um the shards it's now clear why we
have written two shards in total one
primary one replica
um
we also have the id we've talked about
that we see the index and then we have
this version field does anybody know why
we write this version field and i can
actually show you how this increases so
if i have a fixed id and i update that
document because they put this same
write or an update
so here you can see that the version
keeps increasing
where could that be useful
yeah
yeah i know the transloc should be in
the background that's not the case um
yes
no not when merging by seconds ah
segments so one thing that elastic yes
please
yes exactly so the elasticsearch like
most
nosql data stores because i'm not sure
elasticsearch is really the core system
in that um don't have multi-document
transactions or no transactions at all
so
how do you avoid concurrent rights that
overwrite each other so the relational
world is kind of pessimistic in that
regard and that has pessimistic
concurrency control where it locks the
document when it writes it so you read
it so you have like you start the
transaction you read it you write it
back you release the transaction and
only then can somebody else update that
document the nosql world is more
optimistic let's say and we call it
optimistic currency control basically
you read a document so i read this
document and it has version four
and then when i write it back i can
specify in my write operation only
overwrite this document if it's still at
version four if something else has
overwritten this document then we're at
version five six seven whatever reject
the right send it back to the client and
the client needs to figure out what is
the right way to reconcile this because
the assumption is the vast majority of
write operations will not run into that
situation so why have that expensive
transaction and locking
we'll just optimistically try to write
if it fails we can still reconcile on
the client and figure out what is the
right way to
go on um so this is why we have that
version and why it's there
um yes please
sorry this is
so that the sequence number and the
primary term um these were added in 7.0
and they added a lot for the resiliency
of elasticsearch so the sequence number
is basically
the counter of write operations within
that chart
and the primary term is if you have a
failover of masternodes the pro that
primary term would increase
so basically it gives you a total order
of operations within that chart um so
you don't have any concurrency bugs
around that those were added in 7.0 and
have since been around for that
i mean it's just a counter um normally
for
this is within this document with the id
this is for all the documents within the
chart
but it's basically a counter and before
somebody um asks what if this role's
over i think you also need to write i
don't know how many billion documents it
it doesn't happen
um this is i think alone um
okay
something that
i've shortly mentioned was that refresh
and i've actually put together a short
demo to show that refresh so
um
i'm creating a new index called
databases one shard it's fine with a
refresh interval of 30 seconds so by
default it would be one second here i'm
saying batch up all the right operations
into that segment for 30 seconds and
only then create a new segment
why would i want to do that
i need to create fewer segments so it's
cheaper i need to do fewer merges
because i have fewer and larger ones so
it's again cheaper and more resource
intensive so if you want to create
increase the right throughput a higher
refresh rate would help you with that
the downside is um
obviously it takes up to 30 seconds to
see a document in a multi-document
operation um so i'm setting this 30
seconds
um
i write the current version of
elasticsearch into that
and then a get is a single document
operation that always happens
immediately
if i do a search
this might now take up to 30 seconds
until i find this
and i can
keep doing this for a while
and at some point it will appear
you have to be patient because it might
indeed take 30 seconds um
well it takes a while now and now it is
here um i can now do a put to update
this document so let's say we release
8.3 which will come out in the coming
weeks or month
um
if i do a get will i get that document
back immediately
yes
um if i do a search without the body
what will i get the document back
immediately
yes it will be the old version because
it probably hasn't been updated yet
um
and again i need to create i need to run
this a couple of times and now it has
been updated
um
you can call a so-called refresh
explicitly to create the segment but
it's kind of expensive so don't do that
what you could do instead in your
request is you can say refresh wait for
so this will
block the write operation until the
refresh has happened so your application
actually knows when to continue and when
it can read that value back in a
multi-document operation
the one place where you mostly stumble
over this artifact is in unit tests or
integration tests because there you
expect to write the document and read it
back immediately whereas in most other
scenarios for full text search
and with a refresh interval of one
second you don't really recognize or
notice it
there's also another optimization that
we have built into elasticsearch since
7.0 that if you do not do a search
operation for 30 seconds we will stop
creating those small segments and only
create them as needed once you do
another search operation we will then
immediately create the segment to make
it searchable but it's basically to
increase the right throughput by not
creating the small segments
unnecessarily
and still giving you quick access when
searching just the first search
operation will have to wait for a one
second refresh until that happens but
that is another
improvement built in under the hood
um
so refresh is one of the things that you
can play around with to increase your
right throughput the other big setting
that you need to set is the heap and
we've had various settings for that
by default i think we had four gigs of
heap by default by the way what if you
have an instance um how much
memory should you give to the heap and
how much should you leave for the rest
of the system
yes
yes that is
that is almost or that was the
recommendation for it for a very long
time
um
we have changed it now and so it got a
bit so we have done a lot of
improvements by now the heap sizes can
be smaller um why do you even leave
space because there is file system level
caching um it's called memory mapping in
the background so it's basically writing
the file to disk and then when you load
it it's being loaded into memory it's
memory mapped and you can quickly access
it and you can leave half or less by now
for the heap or for the heap and the
rest for caching and to keep your system
running
we have also changed defaults but
elasticsearch by default will now take
half of the memory of your instance
and assumes it's the only service
running on your server that is another
thing that sometimes tricks people
because they have five things running on
a server and don't configure the heap
explicitly and then elasticsearch is
very greedy and just say takes half
because it assumes that's you want to
give the entire node to elasticsearch
that's the default assumption if you do
that you need to reconfigure your heap
or it generally makes sense to configure
your heap explicitly because otherwise
elasticsearch will be greedy and take
everything it hands kanju thinks is the
right amount um to make that faster in
the long run
um
one other thing that is important for
especially if you have something like
time series data so any logs matrix
traces or anything that ages out
is previously all the data was the same
which was kind of stupid because if the
data has a life cycle you often have
like the so called hot data which is
like you write it today and you do most
of your search operations today and then
the data from yesterday to a week ago is
like warm so you don't write to it
anymore or maybe only very little
you do fewer searches and then you have
the code tier which is i always call it
the compliance tier when you need to
keep the data around the logs around for
a year because somebody might need
something but most of the times nobody
does
and why would you keep all of them on
the same hardware profile it's very
wasteful
so what what we generally would have is
um we have hot notes um
warm and then
cold or
now we also have a frozen here but i'll
ignore that for now
um
and what you do is today's write
operations come into this one
and this is this is a very beefy note um
where you keep relatively little data on
it because it has all the right
operations in most of the search
operations once it ages out it moves the
data to a warm node where it keeps it
around for mostly search operations and
then this is like the compliance layer
all of this we have built into the
cluster now and we call it ilm
which stands for index life cycle
management
and it's basically built in or it's not
basically it is built into the
elasticsearch cluster and and you can
configure a policy um
how or when to move the data through the
different stages and so you can use more
optimized hardware profiles if you have
any logs metrics or traces we would
highly recommend to do that you can also
configure when it should roll over from
one index to another index so you have
evenly sized charts
previously people were often using daily
indices
and then on saturday and sunday you
probably had very few logs and very tiny
shards and on the weekdays you had a lot
which was not great so you want to have
those evenly sized
um
so that is kind of like the this how i
we would recommend to structure anything
that you have for time series um if you
want to run any benchmarks um so we
publish a lot of benchmark scenarios um
and like i've said before our favorite
statement is always it depends
because there are so many different
scenarios based on
read write ratios how large are
documents how many updates do you have
what is the general use case what is
your hardware profile um and this is
like this will scroll down here
almost forever and where we where we
benchmark everything every night um we
try to avoid it's the called the the
slow boiling frog problem
anybody from france here so you know
where it's coming from you know when you
when you take the frog
and you throw it in the boiling water it
jumps out immediately
but if you put it in the cold water and
slowly turn it up it sits there and
thinks everything is fine until it's
boiled and you want to avoid that with
your own systems because it gets today
this commit makes something a little
worse and that other commit makes it
even worse so your your performance
suffers over time um so that's why we
have these nightly benchmarks on
dedicated hardware
so we figure out when we are being
boiled by our own slowness
to counteract that and actually the tool
to do that is
called rally
which we call a macro benchmarking uh
tool for elasticsearch it has so-called
tracks um where you can benchmark if you
have any scenarios where you are very
concerned about the performance of your
system we would generally recommend to
build the scenario in rally and then run
those benchmarks to figure out for
your data for your hardware for your
reads and writes what makes sense and
what gives you enough performance
okay i think i've covered most of the
things
any questions
yes please
it it actually okay
okay
yes yes
unfortunately yes i don't have vlogs
any other
comments and before you all run off i
always try to take a picture with you so
i can prove to my colleagues that i've
been working today
can you wave
thank you very much um
final questions otherwise i'm around for
the rest of the day there are stickers
when you go out um please take the
stickers so i don't have to take them
anybody wants a final ball
oops sorry um
thanks so much enjoy the rest of the day
you